hi I'm Rick I'm John I'm Wendy Wendy and
John and Greg are gonna watch a video
from the warp zone ooh fantastic shun
from the man who requested this first
Gabe licked vac good job you react to
the yeah Litvak sounds like a horrible
position that's nice to say about
somebody's name let's just his last name
but we're gonna watch the actual oh man
Logan okay yeah the whole thing the
whole thing is you and I have found a
half hours of Logan's final outing right
here on the real reason emotion
[Music]
what is every ball Logan you're gonna
miss tapioca Tuesday oh my god did a
story of the Dark Phoenix saga I think
it was in 1980 was Jubilee part of the
team back then no no no it must have a
1979 yes Logan no no I can figure this
out
Charles and I just went to see The
Empire Strikes Back just before then so
it was definitely 1980 it's fine just
keep going mmm this is good tapioca the
first time I had tapioca pudding was in
World War two okay and our negative 23 I
23 oh he's fallen and he can't get up
from perfectly natural causes and we
free the sea
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you please stop this no yeah yeah
they're gonna take me back
mr. Logan if you keep this up you're
gonna miss the Canasta tournament Oh
Canasta let's turn this baby around oh
my dearest rogue how come you never call
me anymore you'd think you'd be a little
more grateful after all the times I
saved your life at least you could do is
face poke me on their tweeters every now
and anyways happy birthday and more like
dealer New Deal anyway back to the Dark
Phoenix saga store didn't have a mohawk
yet so that means it was before God gene
gets corrupted by the Phoenix force
turning into the Dark Phoenix pendant
you have to sacrifice yourself to save
everyone you've told me this story a
million times
oh well that cuts deep I didn't know it
was such a burden to you yeah you kids
are all go-go-go these days but if you
slowed down every once in a while and
listen you might learn something but hey
what do I know
I'm almost 200 years old you say
does it matter anymore Logan I'm I'm
sorry I you're a treasure trove of
wisdom and I should appreciate the time
that I have with you rather than just
hoping I'd be over I sometimes I forget
that the elderly have a place in value
in this world and they should be treated
with respect
Logan
he's old yeah oh did he fall asleep
again yoga you mind if I do oh hey folks
thanks a lot you ride
wow what more hook Manny in your life
one of these doohickeys up that was fun
that's fun hey guys you know I just
realize right now this very second what
did you realize you know how I was like
freaking out earlier about all the
technical difficulties oh you have good
reason to be and then I was like oh man
you know what I should stop freaking out
there's one more thing look how much
better than most whoo-hoo I'm doing my
proper breathing techniques right now
active whoo meditating yo couch yeah
that was really funny I feel like I've
seen the warp zone before I don't know
what video they've done only criticism
is that it could have been like a man
short yeah I mean there was certain of
the scenes you you got the point yeah
but you know it's actual old man Logan
so you know that's real much slower I
loved how he was bald here yeah yeah a
lot of funny sight gags and some good
timing and I'm always a sucker for those
jokes worth like really intense and then
we cut to like it's really compared to
the actual
I mean I think I think this one's gonna
give actual Logan run for its money yeah
okay wow that's I mean I heard this
actor at warp zone spent like nine
months prepping you can you can tell
them you know minutes being in that
wheelchair it's like even when he's not
talking you feel a history like he's
been around for 200 years the girl who
played Laura was a thing is way harder
pay because she's older and B that's the
only reason oh and the nice addition of
the yellow robe like you noticed I don't
think Shawn knows it was yellow
I didn't notice like the significance
until you pointed out I feel they can do
another one before it's like a bunch of
that's one thing that would have made it
funny like they kept on bringing up like
they brought storm and Phoenix but I
would like to see you know somebody else
this is a proof of concept for a web
series about just all the old x-men do
you guys have old people in your life
who behave like this kind of old person
they're not quite as kooky oh yeah no
I'm not quite as kooky I also don't have
and that's true that's a missing element
for a lot of people yeah or amazing hair
that's true
hey there's some old people who
surprised especially nowadays
yeah like Kristian harloff has a good
head of hair for a man in his sixties it
was like 63 right he's not sensitive
about this
I don't like you meeting Jeff
descriptions like so oka he'll attack me
and I just find it funny I would love to
meet an actual old person like this
someone who's like a little paranoid
forgetful yeah somewhat dirty I don't
want to be Robert De Niro from dirty
grandpa I'm glad we extrapolated it that
far like older folks after hours yeah
exactly you don't be buoyant here
manners out the door I'm just surprised
it wasn't a viagra joke
that's classic old man juice you need a
viagra gee I'm sure they're gonna do a
part two extended cut yeah well with the
DC movies like extra oh thanks for a
half hour all right well you can
subscribe to the warp zone where I'm
sure they have a couple more videos that
are sketches they have over a million
subscribers which is like oh man a
quarter of what we have yeah that that
reverse math I showed you yeah yeah
which I base all my numbers on yeah
that's why I'm losing this apartment if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real region yeah
Jonah's reading tsageri on Twitter and
Instagram he's a social media manager of
the real rejects in Blum house.com
Wendy Lee is on the movie couple channel
and she is also in Collider videos those
reactions on the movie couple channel
and movie reviews and on Collider movie
talk she's one of the hot girls on
Collider actually knows movies Collider
honey is that like part of the fun the
collider is like hi
not like the requirement to be a part of
a Collider female you gotta be hot
that's the thing just have to be hot
girls John Campea are up to something